on prime crime tonight an adored teacher
disappears this beloved uh
person uh you know goes missing and
just vanishes off the face of the planet
sinister details are revealed
but do we really know what happened
romans 3
23 says for all have sinned
and fallen short of the glory of god
[Music]
good evening everybody i'm jesse weber
and welcome to prime crime tonight
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable
true crime cases tonight the mystery
surrounding a missing woman
and the stunning revelations south of
atlanta and nestled in irwin county
lies ocilla georgia it's a very small
community
everybody literally knows everybody else
a quiet city known for its farming
and sweet potato festival would be
rocked by a chilling development
october 2005 was the beginning
of one of the most painful journeys that
i think any family
could ever be faced with on october 24
2005 former beauty queen and history
teacher tara grinstead
eerily doesn't show up to work at irwin
county high school
she was last seen at a cookout in her
neighborhood two days earlier
and is believed to have driven home at
around 11 p.m
can you imagine living in a small town
and this beloved
person you know goes missing and
just vanishes off the face of the planet
the georgia bureau of investigation
would launch
a massive probe looking into various
theories from suicide
to possible involvement by ex-boyfriends
like army ranger marcus harper
who had a difficult relationship with
tara but in the end
alibis and a lack of evidence would dry
up leads
and the case would go on for years
then in 2016 something happened
around six months ago i was surfing the
web i was looking for cold cases and
other unsolved mysteries
atlanta filmmaker payne lindsay launches
the up and vanished
podcast focusing on tara's disappearance
which brings new eyes and attention to
the story
i think that the podcast really did stir
things up again
the case was cold when i got involved
with it
and the podcast basically caused
everyone in the town to start talking
again
in 2017 breaking news police arrest
ryan duke and beau dukes the two
are not related but they're close o
and ryan were high school friends and
they both had had been students at
irwin county high school where tara
grinstead had been a teacher
in fact maybe even been in her classes
all right now it's time to look
carefully at the evidence against both
these men
and as we go through it let's ask what
is the real story here
before the suspects are apprehended in
2017
let's go back to 2016 when john
mccullough
a former army buddy of beau dukes
reaches out to investigators about a
conversation he had with dukes in 2006
something that until this time he
seemingly disregarded
as dukes just being drunk at the time a
recorded call between mccullough and gbi
agent jason shadell
is released to the public he's like do
you remember
you know that sign that was in town and
i was like yeah
it's like the one that i'd asked for
about because i was like man that's a
pretty lady i was like that's kind of
you know kind of
because i noticed you know that said hey
this new person you know all this other
stuff and
you know and uh he was like well
i know what happened to her in this
shocking twist
dukes claimed his friend murdered tara
and then he helped to clean up the
evidence
by burning her body on his family's
pecan orchard he was like you know
it takes 12 over 1200 degrees to burn
human bones
you know and he said that a couple of
times you know
prior to whenever he's sitting there you
know
telling me
[Applause]
after agent chadell speaks to mccullough
he then questions beau dukes
about this i mean he was pretty adamant
that you know you had made some comments
regarding like burning a body
and i mean that's i mean now you
understand why
you know it's just one of those things
that no no no
i mean i remember it was in the
newspaper and all but
no well you know i mean
but we have to ask the question yeah i
understand you know
um so you didn't help anybody
you know burn her body get rid of her or
any of that good stuff no he needs
that interview that would result in
duke's arrest
why fast forward to february 2017
duke sits down with shell and admits he
was holding something back
something big
[Music]
beau claimed that his friend ryan duke
confessed to murdering tara
and left her body on bo's family's pecan
orchard
he then agrees to go to the site to
check this out
and he showed me where
and
freaked out god uh
asked them what the hell would he told
me that he had
gone to her house that night
he's a credit card he kicked him through
the front door rock
and train wearing the bed
strangulation is one of the most
intimate
uh intimate uh methodologies for taking
another's life because it is very
intimate you have to get within that
close space
for such a violent killing though dukes
describes an
unusual set of injuries on tara can you
describe
[Music]
okay if you just place this person on a
solid surface like before or even on the
bed
you gain the upper hand in this event
and you choke her out it's not going to
require a tremendous amount of pressure
in order to facilitate this you might
not even need
to knock her about at all first off
she's in total shock dukes then
acknowledges in horrific detail
how he did in fact burn tara's corpse
[Music]
this would be confirmed by the gbi when
they excavated the burn site
and found charred remains of human bone
i had to have used
an accelerant like a gasoline or some
type of petroleum product just to get it
started but once that
started they'd have to be prepped with
wood on place to fuel the fire and this
is a constant
not just supplying the fuel but stoking
the fire
that's not all authorities recovered a
latex glove outside tara's home
testing identified both tara and ryan
duke's dna on the glove
strangely though according to bo's
interview this doesn't make sense
[Music]
so
[Applause]
i think that it's scientifically
implausible uh
that duke's dna and tara's dna
just miraculously winds up on the glove
you have to have an individual wearing
this glove they have to have had contact
with both individuals that's how it gets
deposited there
ultimately prosecutors indicted ryan for
tara's murder
and beau was charged in connection with
lying to investigators in 2016
and helping to dispose of evidence a big
issue though is whether these two could
have been arrested
earlier especially since it's been
alleged these men
bragged about what they did at a party
weeks
after tara vanished and dukes admitted
he told
other people over the years including
his ex-girlfriend brooke sherinan
who tipped off the police in 2017.
we're talking about an area that is very
very sparsely populated so it leaves me
and i hate the monday morning
quarterback but it leaves me to ask the
question
was everything pursued that could have
been pursued at that moment in time the
gbi had said
bo and brian's names never came up
before but evidence suggests
that's not true it was told to me that
years ago just a few weeks after she
went missing local law enforcement went
out there based on a tip
that they heard that ryan duke and bo
dukes had murdered tara
they went and searched out on this pecan
orchard and they were turned away
and that information was then given to
the gbi
so so in fact these guys names
were on their radar for this long it
makes you wonder
one why didn't they continue
investigating this
and two what turned them away in the
first place
misstatement by the gbi or if it was
just they
weren't aware of what was in their own
case file it's probably
probably that they probably just didn't
realize that they had these these names
until they went back and looked at their
file but it was a
big misstep whatever may be the case the
reality is we're now left with duke's
account
and while physical evidence corroborates
certain elements of the story
some argue something feels off why did
he agree to say these things to law
enforcement
why would ryan do this and maybe someone
was hiding something
but i do think that ryan duke and beau
dukes are both involved
in her murder but i do think that um
maybe beau dukes is more involved than
he's saying he is when we come back
we're going to focus on the question
that people continually debate
who exactly is the killer this is a
simple
question but why don't you tell me then
what's you're telling me
[Music]
or anything just strainer no they look
like that i mean
everything looks sort of weird
i mean i've seen somebody sense that
tara grinstead disappeared suddenly in
2005 and would take over 10 years for
suspects ryan duke and beau dukes to be
caught
but if you think this is an open and
shut case
think again bo dukes told investigators
that his friend ryan duke
strangled tara to death he assisted in
burning the body
and then lied about it to authorities
but a closer look at the case
raises doubts as to who actually killed
tara
let's start with ryan duke's motive
i
[Music]
that brings us to ryan duke himself who
allegedly confessed to police as well
according to reports he claims he broke
into tara's house to steal money for
drugs
and then killed her when she caught him
in the act that narrative
raises suspicions too i've never bought
the idea that this was a garden variety
burglary gone bad where somebody just
walks in
for purposes of committing some kind of
a theft you know i used to be
a police officer in that town and it's a
really really small place
and i've seen that house and i know what
was in it and
there was nothing of value there would
be nothing
served for anyone to burglarize that
house
there's no signs of forced entry so as
an investigator one of the things that
you
begin to do and kind of process through
all this thing
is well this is a burglary uh
wouldn't there be some evidence that
someone tried to gain
access to an area in which they had that
something was denying them
some kind of physical impediment like a
lock or something such as this or a bar
that doesn't exist here there's also the
matter of what dukes noticed about tara
when he saw her body
he takes you to this orchard and is the
body covered up with anything
it was not close at all
and it wasn't covered with anything it
was like
fesa
yet according to dukes ryan says he
didn't sexually assault the former
beauty queen
there was some kind of intimate
understanding between the two people
i can't speak to tara's uh
personal habits of walking around the
home but it does seem odd
why else would you have a body
that is totally new what what else would
be the motivation unless it was revenge
for something
there there seems to be uh potentially a
an underlying sexual current here that
something did in fact occur the problem
with that jesse
is that that's very difficult to prove
maybe there's not a clear reason for why
duke would murder tara
because he didn't do it his attorneys
argue that he was on drugs and provided
a
false confession to police
someone can believe that they
need to tell law enforcement what law
enforcement wants to hear
they might believe that it's in their
best interest
to frame things in a certain way there's
all sorts of reasons why people
really do falsely confess to to a crime
although duke's lawyers concede he
helped to cover up the crime
they say he's not the killer and it's
been alleged
that he's scared of beau he told me that
he was scared of
what beau would have done if he would
have come forward but
other than that i know some argue it's a
bit strange that beau would help ryan
dispose of human remains instead of
calling the police
beau seems to claim he had no choice
once ryan
showed him tara's body on his family's
property
[Music]
it's even odd that beau decided to admit
to law enforcement about what he did
on one hand maybe he had a guilty
conscience
it's like
we have issues you want to talk to
somebody
then again agent shidell asked him why
he didn't just tell the truth in the
2016 interview
that's what leads to the idea that beau
dukes
may not be as honest as he claims after
all it's arguably very convenient that
beau admits to only getting involved
after tara's death it sort of gives the
appearance of someone who is trying to
maybe minimize their own conduct
and throw someone else under the bus so
that they they can avoid
the mandatory life sentence that goes
along with
with murder so the idea is that you can
confess to a piece of it because maybe
law enforcement
knows that you were or a participant but
if you can say okay i was there but i
really wasn't
that much involved you can maybe sort of
spin
your version of events in a way that's
that's helped
the theory that beau dukes is the real
killer could be supported by a story
that payne lindsay was told by an
unnamed source
in which he shared on up and vanished
years ago
his um his brother picked up what he
thought was ryan duke from a bar
in ocilla and this man told him that
um one time he blacked out and he
thought that he killed somebody
and something about that story just
rings true to me what if he thought that
he did kill terror instead
but he doesn't even really remember what
if these guys were messed up that night
know that false memories
occur we know that people can
be subject to the the power of
suggestion
you can take a person and tell them that
they did something
and actually get them to believe it so
there are a lot of people who think that
that might be the case here
a lot of people believe that well maybe
the roles are reversed
okay maybe it's maybe it's beau dukes
who committed this crime and suggested
to ryan
that that that's how it happened here's
what we do know
beau dukes went to trial in wilcox
county and was convicted of lying to
authorities
concealing tara's death and helping to
prevent ryan's arrest
after a heart-wrenching impact statement
from tara's stepmother
he did nothing he just went on living
his life
not caring about the pain he had caused
to others
he knew she was never coming back he
could have at least told us that
but he didn't he himself spoke out in
court
this is terrific family i'm truly sorry
your long suffering has been
unimaginable
my actions are cowardly callous
and cruel i was more interested in
self-pity
and self-preservation than doing the
right thing for tara
and for you i pray for your forgiveness
but the judge wasn't having any of it
romans 3 23
says for all have sinned and fallen
short of the glory of god
we all have
but that would have been the time to
come forward
dukes was sentenced to 25 years in
prison
at the time of this recording dukes
faces a separate trial in ben hill
county related to the burning
of tara's body ryan duke's murder trial
has been delayed
as he now appeals to georgia's supreme
court asking for the state
to pay for defense experts there's a big
fight over money the defense wants to
hire expert witnesses because if you're
going to convince the jury
that your client's confession was a
false confession you've got to be able
to back that up
he's in no hurry he says look you know
i've got i'm guilty i've told him i've
committed
at least these other crimes i'm gonna
have to do a lot of prison time anyway
so i may as well just stay here in the
local jail keep my mouth shut
not press for a speedy trial because
guess what happens over time
evidence gets stale witnesses disappear
it's much harder to try a case
years and years and years after an
arrest and there's even uncertainty
if we see any trial whether any of these
cases ever come to trial
is questionable in my view at this point
because our court system is so backed up
and you know in the case of beau dukes
for example
he's going to be in prison already for a
very long time
as these legal proceedings continue what
we will ask
is who killed tara grinstead i can't say
from anything that i've
read that i've learned that sources have
told me about i can't say
definitively that poe is not the killer
and i think that it's very plausible
that he might be at the
end of the day with this case
the science is going to tell and you
have to ask this question
what is the source of the dna and from
an investigative standpoint
who had the biggest motivation
and i think it's going to be you know
one person's word
versus the other person's word and that
could get very interesting i think
a mystery since 2005 has started to
unravel and while we seem to know
more details about what happened we
still have
questions that we may never know the
answers to
that's all we have for you on prime
crime tonight give us your comments on
the tara grinstead case on twitter and
facebook with the hashtag
primecrimetonight
thank you for joining us and until next
time be safe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you